nestled in the shadows of Utah's great
national parks 50 miles northwest of the
Grand Canyon is an extraordinary place a
33 thousand acre animal sanctuary called
the best friends it's a refuge like none
other
all kinds of animals call this no kill
shelter home from pets to wildlife to
farm animals in dog towns canine
facility no matter how sick badly
behaved or seemingly unadoptable dogs
who might otherwise be euthanized find
hope a full staff of trainers
and veterinarians devote their entire
lives to transforming every dog into
somebody's pet a staff of over 60
oversees around 500 dogs in 15 different
lodges their main goal turning damaged
dogs into loving pets among the most
challenging cases aggressive dogs their
red collar signals that this dog could
bite but even dogs that appear harmless
sake thank you may have shocking
histories every year dog town takes in
hundreds of canines from all over the
world
staff members work hard to connect every
dog with a potential family three out of
four find permanent homes usually within
months
some dogs adopt more easily than others
but medical condition is always critical
to adopt ability dog town vet dr. patty
I am Pietro reassesses Polly one of
three puppies rescued at the Navajo
Nation in northern Arizona one month ago
little Polly has come a long way
considering the fact she was found along
the side of the road in the desert in
the middle of the summer the fact that
she lost a little bit of vision in her
right eye is probably a small price to
pay
considering the life she's going to have
now with dr. Patty's medical approval
Polly's now ready for adoption over on
their backs and fetal them like a baby
today Tiki Hemi and Polly take their
first steps toward adoption dog towns
puppy socialization class give them the
command to go play and just let them run
loose dragging the leashes around to
learn the skills that will make them
successful pets puppies must be
socialized in the first four months of
their lives
this is Polly's first time on a leash
she's getting used to the sensation
having a little bit of resistance she
doesn't get to go everywhere she wants
to go and that's the first step just
kidding I'm used to having something on
their neck
once without hope these lucky puppies
have their entire lives ahead of them
thanks to dog town they're destined for
loving homes